MAY BE IN BIG TROUBLE TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST AN IMPORTANT
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT WE START
WITH WHAT IS SHAPING UP TO BE
A HORRIBLE BAD FIVE DAYS FOR
ROBERT MUELLER AND THE OFFICE
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THIS OUT-OF-CONTROL WITCH HUNT
SUFFERED TWO MASSIVE MAJOR
BLOWS.
ON FRIDAY IN WHAT WAS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST BEAT-DOWN I
HAVE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE, A
FEDERAL JUDGE UTTERLY REBUKED
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AND HIS
INVESTIGATION, SLAMMING ITS
POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS AND
CALLING OUT THE SCOPE FOR
BEING WAY OUT OF BOUNDS AND
WAY BEYOND THEIR MANDATE.
NOW THE JUDGE'S NAME IS T.S.
ELLIS III.
HE TOLD A TOP MUELLER
PROSECUTOR, LISTEN TO THIS --
WATCH.
"YOU DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT
MR. MANAFORT'S BANK FRAUD.
WELL, THE GOVERNMENT DOES.
WHAT YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT IS
WHAT INFORMATION MR. MANAFORT
CAN GIVE YOU THAT WOULD
REFLECT ON MR. TRUMP OR LEAD
TO HIS PROSECUTION OR HIS
IMPEACHMENT OR WHATEVER.
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE REALLY
INTERESTED IN."
WOW!
THEN ELLIS CONTINUED --
>> Sean: THIS GOES BACK TO
2005.
THE JUDGE ALSO QUOTED --
>> Sean: NOW ELLIS FINISHED
HIS EPIC BEAT-DOWN BY SAYING
SAYING --
>> Sean: THIS DRESSING DOWN
WASN'T THE ONLY LEGAL SET-BACK
FOR TEAM MUELLER.
ON SATURDAY YET ANOTHER
FEDERAL JUDGE DENIED THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S REQUEST FOR
A DELAY IN ITS CASE AGAINST
RUSSIAN ELECTION STROLL FARMS.
AND MEANWHILE, A SERIES OF NEW
POLLS ARE SHOWING MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT IS BECOMING MORE
AND MORE UNPOPULAR, WITH YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ALL WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POLL NUMBERS CLIMB TO HIS
HIGHEST LEVELS EVER.
LATE FRIDAY WE LEARNED A
FORMER MEMBER OF MUELLER'S
TEAM OF INVESTIGATORS, THERE
SHE IS.
F.B.I. LOVE BIRD LISA PAGE
RESIGNED IN DISGRACE MONTHS
AFTER HER VICIOUSLY ANTI-TRUMP
TEXT REVEALED EXTREME BIAS AT
SOME OF THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
THE F.B.I.
AND PAGE WASN'T ALONE IN
RESIGNING.
ANOTHER PROMINENT DEEP STATE
F.B.I. OFFICIAL, LONG-TIME
COMEY ALLY JAMES A. BAKER.
HE ALSO RESIGNED LATE ON
FRIDAY.
SO IS THE DEEP STATE NOW
STARTING TO CRACK?
LOOK, WE ARE LEARNING EVEN
MORE POSITIVE NEWS ABOUT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REVIEW OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S E-MAIL CASE.
HIS TESTIMONY BEFORE CONGRESS
HAS BEEN POSTPONED.
BUT FOR AN INTERESTING REASON.
AFTER REPORTS SHOW THAT THERE
IS FINDING, HE IS FINDING NEW
LEADS IN THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
WE'LL HAVE IT ALL AND BREAK IT
DOWN WITH SARAH CARTER, GREGG
JARRETT AND DAVID SHONE IN A
MINUTE.
BUT OTHER NEWS, IRAN, THE DEAL
IS IN THE BALANCE.
THREE YEARS AGO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SIGNED OFF ON
WHAT THEY PROMISED TO MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER, SAFER PLACE.
IN REALITY THE IRANIAN NUCLEAR
DEAL SENT BOATLOADS OF CASH,
$150 BILLION WORTH, TO A
REGIME ACTIVELY PLOTTING TO
DESTROY THE UNITED STATES AND
OUR BEST ALLY ISRAEL.
ALL WHILE FUNDING TERRORISM
AND PROXY WARS AROUND THE
WORLD.
DEATH TO AMERICA, DEATH TO
ISRAEL.
ALL TOLD WE SPENT $1.7 BILLION
IN YOUR CASH TO IRAN.
THEN WE UNFROZE $150 BILLION
IN ASSETS.
WE LOOSENED SANKS.
WHAT DID AMERICA GET IN
RETURN?
THE PROMISE FROM THE MUELLER
CHAMPING DEATH TO AMERICA THAT
THE ROGUE ISLAMIC THEOCRACY
WOULD TEMPORARILY HALT THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM.
OF COURSE WE KNEW THE MUELLERS
OF IRAN WERE LIARS.
LAST WEEK THEY WERE PROVEN
LIARS BY THE ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER BENJAMIN NETANYAHU
WHEN HE UNVEILED IRAN'S SECRET
PLAN TO FURTHER NUCLEAR
AMBITIONS INCLUDING A PROJECT
AIMED TO CREATE FIVE WARHEADS
EACH CONTAINING A TEN KILATON
YIELD.
GIVEN THE DAMNING RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOW SET TO DECIDE THE FATE
OF THIS AGREEMENT TOMORROW AT
2:00 P.M. EASTERN.
11:00 PACIFIC.
LET US BE CLEAR.
THE MUELLERS OF IRAN ARE NOT
GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE KILLED AMERICANS IN
IRAQ AND THEY FOUGHT PROXY
WARS AND THEY WANT DEATH TO
ISRAEL AND DEATH TO AMERICA.
YOU CANNOT TRUST PEOPLE LIKE
THIS.
THIS AGREEMENT DOES NOT
SUFFICIENTLY CHECK THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAMS.
BUT NONE OF THAT SEEMS TO
MATTER TO FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE JOHN KERRY.
BECAUSE THIS DEAL WAS THE
SHINING JEWEL OF HIS TIME IN
THE OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT.
HE IS REPORTEDLY PULLING OUT
THE STOPS TO SAVE THE HORRIFIC
DEAL WHICH PUTS THE WORLD IN
DANGER.
INCLUDING MEETING WITH IRAN'S
FOREIGN MINISTER.
REALLY?
AND OTHER FOREIGN OFFICIALS
FROM GERMANY AND FRANCE AND
THE E.U. WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THE AGREEMENT?
THIS SHADOW DIPLOMACY
UNDERMINES THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND IT
NEEDS TO STOP.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED THIS --
>> Sean: KERRY SPOKESMAN
RESPONDED IN PART --
>> Sean: OF COURSE, BUT THIS
REVEAL YET, WHAT?
ANOTHER STANDARD IN THE
TWO-TIER JUSTICE SYSTEM.
LET ME REMIND YOU.
REMEMBER THE FORMER ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL SALLY YATES
TOLD CONGRESS GENERAL
MICHAELFLIP WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED -- MICHAEL FLYNN
WAS BEING INVESTIGATED IN PART
OVER LOGAN ACT VIOLATIONS
AFTER HE SPOKE TO THE SOON TO
BE COUNTERPART RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATOR DURING THE TRUMP
TRANSITION.
I REPEAT, THE TRUMP
FLYNN WAS PREPARING TO TAKE
OVER AS THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER BUT THERE IS NO LOGAN
ACT VIOLATION FOR JOHN KERRY?
WHERE ARE THE AGENTS IN THE
F.B.I. AND THE D.O.J. BREAKING
DOWN JOHN KERRY'S DOOR?
ANOTHER PLAY TANT EXAMPLE OF A
TWO-TIER -- BLATANT EXAMPLE OF
A TWO-TIER JUSTICE SYSTEM
TODAY.
WE'LL HAVE FULL ANALYSIS OF
THE INCREDIBLY FLAWED IRAN
DEAL AND KERRY'S UNAUTHORIZED
ACTION.
WE ASK THE QUESTION TONIGHT.
DID JOHN KERRY VIOLATE THE
LAW?
BUT FIRST, THE OBSTRUCTION AND
THE STONEWALLING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE REACHED
A FEVER PITCH.
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
REQUESTED AND SUBPOENAED BY
THE HOUSE JUDICIALIARY
COMMITTEE, BY THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, AND BY
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE ARE
STILL BEING SLOW WALKED AND
WITHHELD OR MASSIVELY REDACTED
IN WHAT IS A CLEAR EFFORT TO
IMPAIR THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT AND DUTY OF CONGRESS TO
CHECK THE D.O.J. AND THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
NOW THE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES WILL JOIN
US IN A SECOND.
HE IS NOW ACTIVELY ENCOURAGING
FELLOW LAWMAKERS TO HOLD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
IN CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
EARLIER TODAY, SESSIONS
RESPONDED.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS WRITTEN HIM A LETTER AND
RESPONDED AS APPROPRIATE TO
HIM.
THE REQUEST HE HAS MADE IS ONE
THAT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITIES AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE FEELS IS NOT
GRANTABLE.
WE HAVE EXPLAINED THAT WE
WOULD BE WILLING TO TALK TO
HIM ABOUT IT BEFORE.
THE DETAILS OF WHICH I
COULDN'T DISCUSS.
>> Sean: MR. ATTORNEY
GENERAL, I SAY THIS WITH ALL
RESPECT.
WHERE IS YOUR URGENCY?
YOU NEED TO DO YOUR JOB.
THIS HAS GONE ON WAY TOO LONG.
THESE ARE LEGITIMATE,
IMPORTANT REQUESTS.
YOU ARE NOT IMPERVIOUS NOR IS
THE D.O.J. IMPERVIOUS TO THE
RULE OF LAW AND OUR FEDERAL
SYSTEM OF CO-EQUAL BRANCHES OF
POWER AND CHECKS AND BALANCES.
THIS IS WITHIN THEIR
CONGRESSIONAL AUTHORITY.
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY.
THE D.O.J. IS CLEARLY
STONEWALLING TO PREVENT
FURTHER EMBARRASSMENT GIVEN
THEIR PATHETIC TRACK RECORD IN
HILLARY CLINTON'S E-MAIL CASE.
THE RAMPANT POTENTIAL WE KNOW
FISA ABUSES.
THE ONGOING WITCH HUNT IN TO
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION WHICH
NEVER HAPPENED.
NOW IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
DOES NOT TAKE SIGNIFICANT
MEASURES TO FIND URGENCY AND
SPEED UP THE DELIVERY OF THESE
REQUESTED FOR MONTHS AND EVEN
YEARS OF UNREDACTED DOCUMENTS,
THEN IT IS TIME FOR SESSIONS,
ROSENSTEIN AND ANYONE ELSE WHO
IS OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS'
INVESTIGATION TO BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT AND FACE THE SERIOUS
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED
WITH IT.
A OTHER WORDS, MR. ATTORNEY
GENERAL, MR. DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL, IT IS TIME TO DECIDE.
YOU PART OF THE DEEP STATE,
ARE YOU GOING TO FIX OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND LET
CONGRESS THE THEIR JOB?
THIS CONGRESS HAS A
CONSTITUTION.
AGAIN, SEPARATION OF POWERS.
CO-EQUAL BRANCHES OF CONGRESS.
CONGRESS HAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
ROLE IN OVERSIGHT.
STOP INTERRUPTING.
THANK YOU FOR THE DISPLAY OF
LEFT WING LUNACY.
THE PICK GINA HASPEL TO LEAD
THE C.I.A.
OVER THE WEEKEND SHE OFFERED
TO WITHDRAW HER NAME FROM
CONSIDERATION.
BAD IDEA.
SHE FACED FIRESTORM OF
CRITICISM FROM THE DEMOCRATS
AND THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY ARE CORRUPT.
BUT GET THIS.
SHE IS CRITICIZED FOR BEING
TOO TOUGH ON TERRORISTS.
HMM, I ACTUALLY LIKE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TOUGH ON TERRORISTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN 2002, SHE RAN A SECRET
C.I.A. PRISON FOR SUSPECTED
TERRORISTS IN THAILAND THAT
USED HARSH INTERROGATION
TACTICS INCLUDING
WATERBOARDING, SLEEP
DEPRAVATION AND EVEN SQUEEZING
DETAINEES INTO COFFINS.
>> YOU HAVE QUESTIONS FROM THE
LEFT AND THE RIGHT FOR HER
ROLE ON THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION TECHNIQUES.
SHE IS GOING TO HAVE A TOUGH
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY.
>> AT THIS MOMENT DONALD TRUMP
IS EFFECTIVELY ACTING THE
U.S. SENATE TO PROMOTORTURE
BECAUSE TRUMP WANTS SOMEONE
WHO HAS TORTURED TO RUN THE
C.I.A.
GINA HASPEL.
>> Sean: DO YOU KNOW AT
GITMO, YOU THE TAXPAYERS PAID
FOR A SOCCER FIELD FOR THOSE
INVOLVED IN ENGAGING AND
KILLING AMERICANS.
AND WE TOOK CARE OF EVERY
DIETARY CONCERN.
AND WE TREATED ONLY THREE
PEOPLE THAT WERE WATERBOARDED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHTLY IS NOT
BACKING DOWN TO THIS
RIDICULOUS CRITICISM.
HE REPORTEDLY HAS PUSHED
HASPEL TO STAY THE COURSE.
I SAY THE SAME THING TONIGHT.
HASPEL'S CONFIRMATION HEARING
WILL TAKE PLACE THIS WEEK.
RIGHTFULLY SO.
I MET HASPEL ONCE.
SHE IS A PATRIOT.
SHE LOVES HER COUNTRY.
SHE HAS WORKED HARD TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SHE MORE THAN DESERVES THIS
JOB.
AND I WILL TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER.
WE SHOULD ALL THANK GOD FOR
PEOPLE LIKE GINA HASPEL AND
THE IMPORTANT WORK THEY DID
AFTER 9/11 TO KEEP THIS
COUNTRY SAFE.
AND SAVE AMERICAN LIVES.
ONLY THREE PEOPLE EVER
WATERBOARDED.
ONE OF THEM, OH, KHALID SHEIKH
MOHAMMED.
AND OTHER FORMER HIGH-RANKING
OFFICIAL.
REMEMBER JOSE RODRIGUEZ ON
THIS SHOW SAID NO WATER